hi everyone my name is christine zagreb
belney I'm a software developer and I'm
a volunteer with the new sanctuary
coalition and this is community driven
development so today we're gonna talk
about your sanctuary coalition's work
we'll talk about the process of building
software to help them scale their work
following the 2016 election and then
we'll talk about how we're building a
community of software developers to
maintain the software and support new
sanctuary coalition's other tech needs
so first new sanctuary coalition NSC is
led by and for immigrants to stop the
inhumane system of detentions and
deportations in this country this is
Ravi Rock beer center he's the founder
and executive director of new sanctuary
coalition in this image he's at his
check-in with ice
surrounded by the new sanctuary
coalition community so NSE is for around
since 2007 and you know over those 12
years they've developed many programs to
resist detention and deportation and all
talk about just four of those programs
now the first is the accompaniment
program which pairs undocumented people
with trained volunteers who accompany
them to their immigration hearings and
check-ins with ice so when our friends
and Friends is new sanctuary collisions
term for our impacted community members
when our friends check in with ice there
are a few potential outcomes they could
be told to come back in six months they
could be told to come back in three
months or a week or they could be
detained on the spot the photo I just
showed of Robbie Rob beer was taken as
he was walking into a check-in in
January 2018 where he was detained for
several weeks and almost deported so the
goal of the accompaniment program is to
provide support you know when you have a
group of people who will wait with you
and sit with you the amount of stress
and anxiety that you feel goes down and
when our friends have to advocate for
themselves whether they have to ask
something of a nice officer or present
their asylum case
to an immigration judge it will be
easier for them to fight for their
rights knowing that they have a group of
people who are standing behind them many
of our friends family members can't come
with them to check-ins because their own
immigration status puts them at risk if
they enter a nice facility so the
accompaniment program can also keep
family members informed and keep NSC
informed during the process the next
program I'll talk about is the pro se
legal clinic which is a weekly clinic
where our friends work with trained
volunteers to plan for and understand
their immigration case so this is an
image from our weekly clinic in New York
in this image you'll see group teams of
two or three volunteers who are each
working with a friend on asylum
applications work authorization other
applications that they will need for
their case and they're supervised by
volunteer attorneys so the anti
detention program works with detained
immigrants across the US and their
families to fight for their release and
usually it's through a strategy that
combines both the legal recourses
available to the person and advocacy so
for example on the left this is BA
bacillus family calling for his release
after he was unexpectedly detained to
his check-in in January 2019 NSE
Community Legal Defense represented Baba
and the NSE community came together to
support him through letter-writing
calling his deportation officer a social
media campaign and on the right and a
see Baba Silla is reuniting with his
family at the NSC offices we also have a
bond fund to help bond people out of
immigration detention and the last
program that I'll talk about
specifically is sanctuary so this is a
network of religious spaces that offer
short and long term physical sanctuary
to friends so immigration authorities
typically don't come into religious
spaces to deport immigrants so if an
immigrant is named as
target for deportation they may decide
to take physical sanctuary and live in a
religious space for an indeterminate
amount of time
this is Amanda Morales on the Left she's
with her children in the church space
where she's living and on the right
she's surrounded by the church community
so these are just four of the ways that
new sanctuary coalition fights detention
and deportation and now we'll take a
look at how technology has helped new
sanctuary coalition scale these programs
over the past three years so when the
2016 election happened I was a volunteer
in the pro se legal clinic and at the
time I was working with a friend and her
son who had just started high school in
New York in Guatemala our friend had
received threatening notes and phone
calls from a gang who is attempting to
extort her one day her son was
approached by gang members at his school
and told to leave the same threatening
notes that his mother had received at
another house knowing that her son's
life was an immediate danger for
refusing gang recruitment and for her
for refusing extortion our friend made
the difficult decision to leave her home
she and her son traveled over a month to
reach the United States from Guatemala
and then she established a new life for
herself and her son in New York after
being detained at the border and making
making her way up to New York we have
been working together for about four
weeks at this point and my small role in
this was to listen and collect all the
required information and put it into an
asylum application which she will then
use as she continues for years to come
to fight to stay here and to keep her
son here as well so for each of our
friends the stakes are extremely high
and when the 2016 election happened
those stakes were compounded
with a new level of fear and as a result
new sanctuary coalition's programs
started growing rapidly over a couple
months we went from having four friends
at clinic every week to 40 which meant
there were 40 teams each working on an
asylum application with a friend and
after clinic NSC staff needed copies of
these applications to review during the
week they needed to track the asylum
application deadlines which are critical
to a friend's case they needed to keep
track of upcoming ice check-ins and
court dates for each friend so they
could be accompanied and this is
difficult enough if every friend and
every volunteer is able to come back to
clinic every week for the four to six
weeks that it takes to complete an
asylum application but of course that's
not possible so there's some amount of
needing to hand off work so this
important progress isn't lost and all of
the sharing documents and triage and
cases and putting together new teams for
whoever you know showed up at clinic
that day had to be completed as quickly
as possible in a small space that was
crammed with a hundred and fifty people
at the beginning of clinic and it wasn't
sustainable and that carried a
potentially huge cost for our friends so
I had a really strong motivation to work
on a solution for this problem
I was I was motivated by this the work
of this community by the leadership of
our friends by volunteers who were
stepping up and meeting challenges on a
daily basis who would stay as late as
necessary to complete an asylum
application with an impending deadline
we have a listserv for volunteers and
staff would send out a message and one
of our friends has just been released
from a detention center in New Jersey
can anyone like drive out there and meet
them and within 10 minutes I'd see
another message saying thanks we got
someone
and I was very motivated by staff who
were not only relentlessly improving
logistics but they were doing everything
that they could to keep to make sure
that no one fell through the cracks so I
had a strong motivation and we needed a
plan and the first part of that is
requirements and because I was immersed
in the work I had a huge head start in
understanding requirements I had a
strong sense of the priority of features
and I also knew what aspects of their
work were likely to change and stay the
same and this was really helpful because
in all of the chaos and you know time
pressure of this moment it wasn't going
to be possible to have all of the
meetings that it takes to get from zero
to 100 in terms of really understanding
these requirements so after we
determined that there wasn't any
software in the market that was going to
meet the most important requirements
that they had I was able to put together
wireframes for a rails application and
the staff worked with me to fine-tune
them and you know since the MVP we have
built features for programs that they're
not currently running but they're
intending to run really soon and those
have always required a lot more
adjustment after the fact because there
are things that I don't anticipate and
they wind up running the program a
little bit differently than they
imagined in practice so now I try to
hold the line and build features for
work that they are currently doing so
after requirements we needed a timeline
and we had a conversation about this and
it was pretty clear that a solution that
wasn't available in three months wasn't
going to be a viable solution so that
timeline helped us set the scope of work
for the MVP a little bit more
conservatively so you know your small
scrappy nonprofits who are doing the
work on the ground they probably don't
know that software needs to be
maintained I don't think that's like
general knowledge but
as a developer I knew that if I built it
I would be on the hook to maintain it so
that was my biggest consideration in
making the decision to offer to build
the MVP I kind of imagined I would be
you know committing to spend a certain
amount of time every week for bug feet
features for bug fixes and feature
requests probably for about you know
three years would be kind of the minimum
and over those several years I've come
to understand that it's it's not just
those two things there's a lot of
project management a lot of QA some
open-source maintainer stuff as well as
security and uptime issues that are also
priorities and obviously I'm using the
term maintenance really broadly to just
mean everything that has to happen for
software to be able to be used over the
long of over the long haul and we've
also seen this play out with
out-of-the-box software that solutions
that we've implemented for them at NSC
because you know you're not going to be
maintaining the code of that software
but they could need you know
configuration changes down the line in
order to be able to continue to use the
software in the long run so I think for
any sort of project whether you're
building custom software or not it's a
good thing to evaluate the long-term
need and you I I knew lastly that there
would be some amount of training and
support required but I definitely
underestimated it I mean I understand
mated how much time it would take and I
also kind of thought it was going to be
a one-time thing versus an ongoing need
but I did a combination of video demos
and in-person training the video demos
get out of date as you add new features
and with in-person training new staff
come on maybe a staff member hasn't used
a feature in awhile and now they need to
and they don't really remember what we
talked about initially and as you build
features that are more complex it's
usually more efficient to talk about
them in person and I'm consistently
reminded about how important this is
whenever I sit down with the staff
and they told me you know oh it would be
so great if the software could do this
and I'm like oh it can and so I'm just
constantly reminded that if they don't
know how to use features in the software
they're not going to and we've also seen
this play out with other out-of-the-box
software solutions that we've
implemented for them another tech
volunteer Rebecca has become an expert
in the volunteer management CRM that
they use nation builder and the software
would honestly be used in a pretty
limited way
if she hadn't invested all the time and
energy in training them how to use the
software and advising them how to use it
and and getting them set up with things
so I had the motivation I had the plan
and the third thing that was really
critical for the project to be
successful with shared values which
really boils down to you know how do you
work with other people in the community
and how do you view the work that you're
doing and these values appear you know
they were developed for new sanctuary
coalition's proce a legal clinic but I
share them because I think many of them
are transferable to work with other
organizations and they've definitely
provided a really strong foundation for
this project so no ego it's not about us
as volunteers no drama
I mean staff deal with emergencies on a
daily basis and in order to move any
sort of project forward you will have to
do more you know legwork and follow up
an accommodation of changing priorities
and so it's important to just empathize
with the challenges of leadership are
facing no Savior complexes as NSC
volunteers we are standing in solidarity
with people who have more courage than
most of us will ever have you when our
friends argue their asylum case in front
of an immigration judge
when they walk into a nice check-in not
knowing if they will come back out when
they are imprisoned for months or years
fighting their deportation they're
putting their body on the line for their
right and the right of others to live in
dignity so our friends are leading this
movement and we are standing behind them
and in the work that you do with
organizations it's really important to
take leadership from impacted community
members problem-solve
so as technologists we have this broad
perspective on technology which can be
really useful in solving problems we
don't just have the languages and
technology stacks on our resumes we kind
of understand how it all fits together
and we're not afraid of it and it's
really important to recognize the value
in that because the important work isnt
the sexy work and it's not necessarily
the work that uses what you think of as
your most valuable skills supporting a
migration 2g suite isn't sexy but if
staff are losing tons of important
emails from funders and lawyers to spam
it might be the most important work in
the moment helping someone get set up
with a password manager is not going to
use your programming or design skills
but it's so critical to protect the
community so you know in addition to
these two things we've had new sanctuary
coalition tech volunteers reimage
donated laptops maintained redesign and
then ultimately migrated like a static
information site and as well as set up a
volunteer management CRM which meant
that they were able to accept donations
securely that they could schedule and
accept RSVPs to trainings that they
could send bulk emails and segmented e
multiple interior's you know that said
it is important to learn
respect your own boundaries and what you
can commit to because not doing that
hurts you but it also ultimately hurts
the organization and lastly you know
total communication there's a lot to be
said for you know being in person as a
volunteer as the basis of your work as a
technologist because you learn how the
organization works who you need to talk
to what's the best way to communicate
with them and you do that without
putting you know additional burden on
staff to provide you with the answers to
these questions and at the same time you
build mutual trust with the people that
you're working with which you know is
really important for good communication
so we had motivation plan shared values
we were able to build the MVP with
functionality that addressed some of the
problems that we talked about earlier we
obviously wanted a central place for
admins be able to access digital records
for the friends a Tennessee is working
with so here they can you know search by
various fields we wanted them to be able
to edit these records obviously we want
them to be able to add upcoming ice
check-ins or court hearings anything
that the friend would be a company -
that's the activities here we wanted
admins to have a running list of all of
the the drafts of asylum applications
and other applications that have been
worked on in clinic you know attach to
the friends record and we wanted
volunteers to be able to upload these
documents for the friend that they were
working with and to do that they needed
to be able to be given access a limited
limited amount of access to a specific
friends record that they were working
with in clinic and this is from the
volunteers perspective they're working
with this friend and clinic they can
view all of the documents that have been
uploaded for the friend to date and then
they can upload new documents when they
have a new version at the end of clinic
and obviously the accompaniment program
volunteers you
now able to RSVP view all the
accompaniments for the next couple weeks
and RSVP to accompany so you know the
program's continued growing and with
support from this software and new
sanctuary coalition's other tech efforts
so you know starting with accompaniments
generally we were doing accompaniments
for about ten friends each week in
August 2017
now we're organizing accompaniments for
between 50 to 70 friends each week
likewise starting with 30 volunteers
accompanying weekly in August 2017 by
summer 2019 you know were somewhere
between 125 175 volunteer shifts being
filled weekly in New York likewise the
pro se legal clinic in August 2017 we
had around 40 friends attending clinic
each week that spiked 150 in spring
before we restructured clinic to keep
the numbers around 100 and make it more
sustainable in the long long term and
the volunteer numbers aren't up here but
we at this point have around 300
volunteers attending clinic every week
in New York and you know once we started
to use the software in production it
became more and more integral part of
new sanctuary coalitions day to day work
and because of that you know it was
really imperative to make it sustainable
in the long term because they didn't
start from a sustainable place my
company does summer fridays so I'd work
half-day Friday Saturday Sunday and then
two nights during a week for about two
and a half months to get the MVP out and
on Sundays I'd get together with a
couple other radical coders and we just
hack on the project for a couple hours
which was huge morale boost so we got to
August 2017
got the got the software deployed got
the users migrated and all the user
invitations sent and then I was I was
really burnt out for a couple months and
you know I wanted to get other
contributors on the project to make it
more sustainable and so I thought hack
events I can I can rope in some
developers there so in August our sorry
in December we participated in our first
hack event it was hosted by progressive
hack night in New York and to get ready
for this I did you know a lot of the
things that first-time contributors need
like good seed data a good readme easy
setup and it also really influenced the
way that I wrote issues because I made a
couple of assumptions I assume that the
developers would not have any experience
with this software they wouldn't know
the codebase I was assuming that I
wouldn't know the experience level that
they would be bringing in and I also
kind of knew from experience that you
know miscommunication around what what
we're building and how we're building it
it really sucks and can lead to a lot of
unusable work and I wanted to avoid that
so to compensate for all of those things
I just started writing really
prescriptive issues that just included a
lot of very specific implementation
details and they took a long time to
write but I thought you know this is
just it's just an investment to get this
long-term contributors that I wanted but
heading into summer 2018 you know we
needed to make the app multi-tenant we
needed to make some changes to support
clinics outside of New York and I kind
of divided that work up into a couple
phases I did a solo sprint to make the
multi-tenant changes which is that big
spike in the middle and then the project
was featured at Ruby for good and we had
a team of engineers all working on the
project for a couple days and knocked
out some of the functionality for
clinics outside of New York and then I
had a final sprint to finish everything
up and get it all merged and deployed
and you know of course after that I was
just burned out again
and you know I realized that I wasn't I
wasn't meeting my goal of getting these
long-term contributors and I had been
putting all of this effort into making
the project just work really well for
HACC events but I wasn't putting any
effort into retaining contributors after
I was introduced to them at these events
so I started thinking about you know
what motivates someone to contribute
long term like what motivated me and
what motivated my current and former
co-workers Tasha and Russell who had
begun to contribute more regularly over
the past year and you know how could I
build on this and make it part of the
experience for everyone so I mentioned
before that you I was really motivated
by community by the new sanctuary
coalition community and that was true of
many of the other volunteers and in
reflecting on how NSE has been so
effective in building this community you
know I realized that there were a couple
different aspects of working in this
community that I wanted to extend and
replicate and the first of those is
connection to the work
so as an NSC volunteer you are sitting
in a nice facility and waiting with
someone you are sitting across the table
and working together on an asylum
application the person-to-person
connection is like a foundational part
of the community and it occurred to me
that Tasha and Russell had been working
on this project for about a year and
they hadn't seen clinic in person they
hadn't seen any of the programs in
person and so first chance I had I
invited them to come to clinic and to
meet everyone and to see the software
actually being used in person and that's
something that I you know continued with
regular contributors whenever and
however I can get them to New York to
that in-person connection with the work
because building a connection to the
work takes time I mean I had been
volunteering with new sanctuary
coalition for three years before I wrote
any code and I realized that one thing
you know but but during that time I I
kept getting email updates from new
sanctuary coalition I kept coming back
eventually I became part of the
community and I really said one thing I
had done with Tasha and Russell was just
kind of keep them in the loop on you
know what was happening at new sanctuary
coalition which was easy to do because
we're friends and we're talking anyway
we just you know kind of come up and so
I realized it was really important for
all the contributors to hear about
what's happening in new sanctuary
coalition on a regular basis so that you
know they can start to build that
connection to the work over time and
become increasingly invested so I
started a new sanctuary coalition tech
monthly newsletter and the first thing
in this newsletter is an update on what
new sanctuary coalition has been doing
this month highlights so that they
understand the work on a deeper level
and you know in addition to
understanding the work more broadly you
I realized it was really important for
them to understand the work the the
impact of their work specifically so
that has definitely informed the way
that I structure issues in the repo when
a contributor picks up an issue the
first thing that they see is a
background section that lays out like
what is the real world need for this
issue what will be better in the world
if this is completed so working together
you know whether it hack events or at
volunteering at NSC in person you know
is an aspect of community that was just
really energizing and I wanted to create
some structure so that this could happen
for this project on a regular basis and
so the first thing was that you know we
host a virtual co-working night each
month on zoom' for a couple hours
contributors can come and go and work
hack
the project and chat and in the monthly
newsletter you know I also shout out all
of the work that we've completed this
month because it's important you know
it's really energizing to see the work
of the tech community as a whole and
what we're getting done together and I
also the monthly newsletter has given me
a structure to provide like regular
invitations for contributors to
participate in the work of the community
so I'm able to preview the current and
upcoming work at a on a regular interval
and you know the last aspect of
community that I want to make sure was
embedded in the project was shared
values and goals so of course you know
we've incorporated new sanctuary
coalition's mission and their values
into our code of conduct but I think you
know these values play out the most in
interactions and decisions that we've
made for example you know we've decided
to include all of the tech projects and
all tech volunteers at NSC in this
newsletter in this community because
it's not just the the code not just the
open source contributions that are are
making the work of his community
possible so because the important work
isnt the sexy work and we want all the
work to be visible and you know if our
goal is to support annecy tech needs
sometimes that's going to involve
prioritizing across different projects
and it's going to involve you know a lot
of different skills not just Ruby and
rails so I hope that you may go out and
decide to be an organization's tech
friend you know go out and find the
organizations in your community that are
led by people who are directly impacted
by the issues that they are working on
and you know organizations who were
doing the work on the ground with no
resources and be part of the
community first and then problem-solve
those big problems or the small problems
and your lastly investing community
because community in your work both as a
technologist and you know as an
organizer is the only way that any of
this is ever going to be sustainable so
thank you I have some links for you you
can learn more about new sanctuary
coalition you can donate to help them
continue to do this work you can donate
to the bond fund we're currently in New
York but we hope to have accompaniment
programs in other states in the future
and if you do a little googling you know
you may find that there is an
accompaniment program run by a different
organization near you you can also you
know contribute to the open-source
project we have open issues at the
moment and learn how you can get
involved with a new sanctuary coalition
tech community more broadly and also
I'll be around after and I would you
know really love to chat with you about
any of this so thank you
[Applause]